hi Nick hey what's up man see we got
waters for you we got coffees all sorts
of stuff there is you said turn
everything on Bobby rat the fur bone
town so uh I brought my x'mas yeah I
didn't like the way his approach was ooh
Chris Hanson yeah that was the big guy
come out of a door sexual prayer Chris
Hanna what he was doing was like you
know you know he was he needed to do
what he was doing because he's stopping
you know that's just the way he would
enter was a little shocking to me cuz I
don't know where I'm imagine you wanna
get your like your guy oh my god I got
you know yonas offhand the creditors
yeah yeah yeah but I like that he would
swoop in with a clipboard and be like
have a seat yeah yet people work with
them yeah which is like there's always
like you are a star master 16 yeah when
you said I want you to taste my [ __ ] I
don't know man I'm here just to hang out
yeah yeah she needed a friend I like
that sometimes they go yeah no I just
wanted to be your friend because try to
protect her from people like me
you're a 52 year old man you want to be
friends yeah yeah yeah and you say I was
good Chris Hanson did and then I go yeah
anyway no I have it this is how the
podcast goes dude we do the countdown we
you don't say I can't be a part of you
no you're not a part of anything you
shouldn't say anything can I say three
no you're on your game to do that
alright alright so before we start we're
not gonna add this stuff so we're not
what we set up so put that down man
it's not your [ __ ] your you want one
it's a rich wallet you know what those
are
I'll show you it seems like a mistake
these are wallets that we all use and
it's got um you put your credit cards
here as era of era RFID protection and
you put your money here you want one I
mean yeah yeah get him one stack it now
it was only these are expensive did you
got one for free dude thank you we
response about them they're great don't
open it now
later yeah just turn everything on
yeah let's turn everything on and until
I say your name you don't introduce me
or for know this is the rule okay I love
you do thanks for coming hey man don't
even touch with your [ __ ] skinny
fingers did you lose weight you look
anyway let's go to start okay I didn't
really into code five four three two one
oh my god I'm gonna put the net in an
app but we could do it again I don't
want to do it again okay but that debt
put me in a rage
I just got raged I gotta put your
[ __ ] so from my Center just list are
you planning on starter Valley go ahead
[Music]